dans ta tête encore bébé de bobo quelque
chose c'est ça
qui parle de Macron de snapchat la
famille de la
bonne année à toutes et à tous ceux
qui sont chiffre d'affaires
et qu'elle sera mieux que l'année
précédente est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
avoir accès aux archives du futur
[Musique]
Michel de Notre-Dame appeler Nostradamus
énorme 1503 à Saint-Rémy-de-Provence il
était un petit cœur tu as fait de
l'année de médecine à Montpellier avant
d'être radié parce que oui à l'époque le
statut de l'apothicaire était
incompatible avec celui de médecin mais
il a quand même exercer la médecine à
Agen en 1534 jusqu'à 1538 dates vers
laquelle il aurait perdu sa femme et ses
deux enfants lors d'une épidémie de
peste et que ne sera la mise va
commencer à faire des prédictions de
1555 à 57 Nostradamus la publier ces
célèbres prophétie qui va écrire en 481
c'est un poème de 4 lignes par la suite
en century c'est-à-dire une série de 104
au total il va publier 700 tu risques de
son vivant et c'était la septième qui
était incomplet
disait qu'il pratiquait également la
bibliomancie c'est quoi ce truc que je
vous faire voir la bibliomancie consiste
à poser une question
à
te poser une question
dans 45 minutes
bon je veux pas piquer la place de
Nostradamus mais j'ai quand même envie
de te dire que certains d'entre vous
vont pas tarder à manger de la galette
une date comme ça au hasard je sens bien
le 6 janvier au final on peut appliquer
cette texte à n'importe quel moment de
tension de l'humanité donc est-ce que
Nostradamus réellement des fenêtres sur
l'avenir ou simplement sur son
imagination moi j'ai ma petite idée mais
d'abord j'ai envie de me prêter moi
aussi à cet exercice avec un abonné je
vais essayer de lui faire de la voyance
version Nostradamus
incroyable
de
psychiatrique
noms des patients dans chaque chambre
qu'ils ont quand est-ce qu'ils sont
rentrés l'admission il y a pas de il y a
pas de notre fait à la main il y a pas
demandé de choisir une salle au hasard
dans ta tête
[Musique]
d'un homme
1936 et moi je le vois arriver dans les
années 1915 ça marche avec ce que tu as
dans ta tête
et je t'invite à feuilleter pour voir
que c'est pas toujours monsieur Barriol
que que c'est
vous et de nombreuses fois parler de
fait barnum et je vous envie de te
regarder la vidéo je me suis fait passer
pour un voyant si vous voulez voir de
façon concrète comment j'ai essayé de ce
procédé pour me faire passer pour un
médium mais maintenant laissez-moi vous
parlez du billet rétrospective ou en
d'autres termes la clairvoyance
rétroactive on appelle ça en fait la
capacité à dire la météo du jour d'avant
mais pourquoi notre cerveau fait ça tout
simplement parce que notre cerveau dicte
est plus il préfère chercher par tous
les moyens rationaliser les événements à
chercher à rendre cohérent le présent et
le passé plutôt que d'accepter qu'il ne
peut pas tout contrôler ni avant
invisibilité surtout ça joue tu as
d'autres bien comme le biais de
confirmation par lequel il est
directement lié le billet c'est le fait
de sélectionner uniquement les
informations qui confirme ce que l'on
pense déjà en résumé nous croyons ce que
nous voulons croire et c'est ma théorie
sur les prédictions de Nostradamus je
pense vraiment qu'on les confirme a
posteriori les prophéties de Nostradamus
century on peut lire la chose suivante
dans le 80 numéro 35 le lion jeune le
vieux surmontera en par singulière duel
dans 15 dort les yeux lui crèvera de
classe 1 puis mourir de mort cruelle que
c'est pas bien clair d'après les
interprètes de l'époque Céline
préciserai avec exactitude la mort du
roi Henri 2 survenu le 30 juin 2559 on
va détaillé ça ensemble pour voir si ça
marche le jeune Lyon et le compte de
Montgomery qui avait un lion pour
emblème le vieux c'est Henri II le roi
de France en chambre parent singulière
du elle fait référence à un amical les
deux classes par le des deux
affrontement en effet il y en aurait eu
de une puis mourir de mort cruelle que
la lance du comte de Montgomery percute
le casque doré du roi du père soleil
Henri mort à 10 jours plus tard dans
d'atroces souffrances comme ça ça c'est
troublant je vous l'accorde mais encore
une fois on a fait le travail après
parce que Nostradamus si tu as aucun
moment le roi de France il donne aucune
indications temporelles lit de lieu dans
ses prophétie Nostradamus
France 2 pluzz les duels à l'époque
était tout à fait courant et en
l'occurrence il s'agissait d'un pour le
mariage du fils de
pour l'époque nous sommes dans le
parfait exemple du biais rétrospectif
une fois d'Henri II est mort tout le
monde se dit
mais il
parle de moi
parce que je
crois que tout le monde
parle
et
du coup je pense que c'est
pour
vous pensez que je vais trop loin mais
n'empêche qu'on peut
voir nouveau spectacle de la tournée de
rodage de mon nouveau spectacle par
plusieurs assistant
dans la salle ça fait plaisir c'est
carrément merci de me prévenir
mur mais comme miracle ils vont
carrément tellement être bluffé que les
murs de la salle vont trembler et ça
c'est un miracle c'est ça que ça veut
dire le roi sauver et 30 des instants le
roi sauver une faiblesse morale parce
que moi spectacle à redonner le moral à
tous ceux qui l'ont perdu en fait vous
voyez là je m'amuse un petit peu avec ça
mais on peut on peut les tordre un peu
comme on veut ça vous paraît Lemonnier
mais c'est vrai comme ça qu'on était
interpréter les prédictions de
Nostradamus j'aurais pu aussi vous
parlez de la montée d'Hitler de
l'élection de Trump du but de Mbappe en
cherchant bien on peut tout trouvé sur
plus de 10 ans il y a moyen qu'on trouve
tout ce qu'on veut croire donc pour
conclure ne perdez jamais vu que vous
êtes les seuls mettre de votre destinée
et aussi de votre penser quand bien même
quelqu'un vous prenne une chute à cheval
ou un gros contrat ne perdez jamais de
vu votre libre arbitre il y a que vous
qui savez et enfin la plus grosse
surprise de cette vidéo régler la
famille de voyant la plus précise
contrairement à Nostradamus il y a des
il y a des noms j'ai longtemps hésité à
vous en parler mais j'ai vraiment envie
de vous le dire il me confier parce
qu'il s'agit des Simpson
vraiment sérieusement
on en parle pas
mais
il est
possible que
je
vais aller
[Musique]
à très bientôt Ciao